damnit one Foreman sunglasses this
entire video because baby wears
sunglasses and it's cool that I could
see the studio like right there the
reflection it's gonna piss me off that
looks like my own eye like I am watching
[Music]
baby driver so baby driver is written
and directed by Edgar Wright in Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world folks I know he
has done a lot more than that but in the
end Scott Pilgrim vs. the world and baby
driver is about a getaway driver named
baby Kevin Spacey's kind of the boss he
puts together a crew but he always uses
baby as his driver why because baby
played by Ansel Elgort
is the best driver in the world period
and I love that I love when his story
has youth who was much better at the
skill than any adult that could have
hired it's like Doogie Howser syndra's
like the Doogie Howser of getaway driver
and baby me - waitress played by Lily
James so we have the romance coming to
the story and they both knows they want
to go away just get away from it all
just dry not for excitement but to just
live their lives but baby is trapped in
this world of crime so we have ourselves
a movie this movie was stylish
how you would you say you're like yep
that's Edgar Wright's Brian alright
every still some fun have yourself some
action have you still some solid comedy
some good laughs and at the core of it
you have something very personal human
even romantic and speaking of the skills
of baby dude that when this dude is
driving you are locked in your yapper
that shot it's in the trailer it goes
down this alley there's a truck parked
sideways he drifts his car - just spin
and slightly miss it and keeps going
that's the kind of style that gets me I
don't know how much of it is real how
much business CGI I imagine I will find
out later it looks pretty legit and his
cinematography is actually fluid and it
really were those high-octane driving
chases guide aways it's easy for a
director Sevilla yeah we're going to
film some stuff with a car then we're
going to cut it's going to go around the
corner in script cut and that's
best-case scenario best-case scenario it
looks like that worst-case scenario it's
choppy as you can't see what's
going on with baby driver when the
getaway driving is happening you're
actually able to tell what the hell's
happening you're following the car
you're mapping its path and in that you
can kind of tell where they're going in
the city which brings you into the movie
more it makes the city feel more real
makes the experience more real in
general high-octane driving that you
will never experience in your life and
it feels real unbelievable yet real I
like Ansel Elgort in this movie he has
an innocence about
he has a thing you know the interesting
characters have a thing you can tell a
good writer and a director from a shame
writer and director when someone's like
that character needs a thing and it
clearly feels like a stupid thing died
his thing is he always listens to music
all the time in that you really feel
like he sees the world through the beats
of music he feels it there's a scene
where he's walking through the streets
you're like I felt like that I have felt
that kind of bliss and happiness with
earphones in and I'm walking and hopping
to the beat it feels like everything
around he is going to the beat two
elements of happiness I feel in the
world the director really conveyed to me
Kevin Spacey was great too I thought
Kevin Spacey was going to be a cameo he
did the movie for a pretty legit amount
of time I thought the romance between
Ansel Elgort and Lilly James was great
when it was happening when they're
talking they clearly have chemistry you
can't deny that I mean wasn't just flirt
talking or like you got more game than I
do dude I can tell you that which isn't
saying much but I'm just saying if I can
pick a negative in this movie and this
isn't something that compromises the
film but it's dinner I feel like the
movie is ten minutes too long again
doesn't compromise the film as a whole
I'm just saying in a world where I have
to choose a negative that's the negative
the guy's baby driver was great I love
the characters in it
I love the leads I love the support the
movie's not as predictable as you feel
like it's going to be given the premise
the world was colorful it was fun it was
exciting it was hysterical in parts it's
enough it doesn't take itself too
seriously it has serious enough elements
in it when the two come together to come
together quite well truly a unique
experience I will say baby driver is
awesome tacular
right guys so baby driver have you seen
it what did you think about it did you
have fun did you break speeding laws I
feel like traffic tickets after this
movie's release are going to go up
tenfold but whatever be fake comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]